so nintendo announced a new switch model
and there's some folks out there who are
a little
confused as to who exactly it's intended
for
on one side people are like yo where's
the 4k
where's the pro where's pikmin 4 i'm the
only one asking for the last part
i know on the other side some other
people are like hey
nintendo never promised those things
those were just rumors
the market doesn't revolve around you so
chill out and lastly
there's the consideration that maybe
this new switch model
isn't actually intended for anyone who
already owns
a switch so let's just take a step back
and ask well who is this for that
because if you're watching this video
whether or not you own a switch
then you're likely wondering the exact
same so
let's just start by getting all the
facts we know out of the way
it's the nintendo switch oled model and
surprise it's got an old lead display
deeper blacks more vibrance that sort of
thing the screen is bigger it's 7 inches
instead of 6.2
it's got a new kickstand improved audio
twice the storage
and its dock now has a built-in lan port
all of which is 350 bucks
everything else is the same same eternal
specs
same old joy-cons and your games are
going to be running the exact
same way so the bulk of it is cosmetic
with a kickstand that you won't have to
tape down because it
dangles like a phantom limb
yeah now with that out of the way
where does this oled model live in the
current
roster of switches back in 2017 we got
this bad boy and yes these joy-cons
are not the ones the console came with
for reasons that i don't have to explain
its display is 6.2
inches it's got an lcd screen and its
battery is
well it gets the job done for a couple
hours
then we got this little puppy aka the
secondary switch i bought so my partner
and i could play animal crossing
together for a total of one month until
neither one of us ever touched it again
it's 200 bucks and it's strictly a
handheld
so this one at 200 bucks and this one at
300 and it's been 300 since it's
launched back in 2017
uh even with a new model that came out
in 2019 with a slightly improved battery
300 200 so where does the oled model fit
in
being 50 more than this dude and 150
more
than this dude let's start with
considering the value of what you're
getting if you were to
buy the oled model you're getting a
kickstand that doesn't suck which would
otherwise cost about 10 to 15 dollars
replaced with an actual
good one a built-in land adapter which
otherwise would have been an external
thing you'd have to buy for about
30 bucks and then you're getting 32
gigabytes of extra storage which is
about 10
depending on where you buy it that alone
has 55 bones and if those are
accessories you'd even consider
buying along with the current base
switch that's on the market
not to mention the bigger and better
screen that comes with the oled model
it kind of feels like a no-brainer
that you would just wait to get the oled
model and then away
the base one kind of feels obsolete in
comparison
with exception that's 50 more but you're
getting more than 50 dollars
worth of value with the olen model now
let's further assume you don't
already own a switch and you're trying
to figure out whether or not you should
just get the switch light or
whether or not you should wait for the
oled model if you're a social person and
you think you'd enjoy playing couch
multiplayer games with friends and
family like mario kart or smash
but still you'll want to take skyrim and
monster hunter rise with you on the
commute to work to school
or the bathroom uh it might be worth
waiting till october 8th for the oled
model
but if you're a cool lone wolf who plays
in bed alone for many hours and doesn't
have a big tv of your own
the switch light is an excellent choice
too now
let's consider you are a switch owner
and whether or not this is actually
even an upgrade so
if you primarily play your switch
handheld and occasionally
dock it bigger screen and oled panel
is pretty damn nice looking but it's
also
350 dollars brand new nice
looking or let's say you've had the same
base model since 2017
it's got a kickstand that needs to be
amputated you've traveled around with it
a lot the battery life still kind of
sucks
and maybe it's fan has gotten a little
loud but you still use it handheld
and occasionally play splatoon 3 on your
tv docked
and maybe i am talking about myself or
maybe not because
if you were to ask me as someone who
owns a switch and
relates to everything i just listed off
i actually don't
know if i would buy this yet
which means i'm considering it
when traveling was a thing and i used to
frequent coffee shops
and equally play video games there as i
did at home
this thing came with me everywhere and
it's been the same one
since day one and it has done me fine
with the exception
but on the other end i do anticipate
traveling becoming a thing again
at the end of this year and if the star
is aligned and i am oh so privileged
enough to drop 350 bones
on a new piece of hardware that'll last
a few years longer
but even just seeing that kind of feels
silly
clearly i'm struggling with answering
this question for myself look at the end
of the day i think
the important thing is if you want it i
see little reason why
not to get it there is really good value
in that thing and the switch is still a
phenomenal console
on the other hand if you don't want it
that's sweet too
or maybe you fall in the category in
which you're a little upset because it's
not
exactly what you wanted and i think your
feelings
are completely justified of course we
all want something more powerful and
sweet and cool to like
play breath of the wild at 60 frames per
second and
all that jazz i get it if anything i'm
not going to give you my opinion on
whether or not we're still going to be
getting a switch
pro but i would ask to at least consider
that
the switch is still doing exceptionally
well and is
rivaling units sold in comparison to the
wii
and that said i don't think nintendo is
hurting to try and
resell itself to people who have already
bought it
and while it's still a four year old
console there's still a
massive demographic of gamers who don't
have this thing and maybe they're
waiting for the next installment to
metroid and in that case
on october 8th when metroid dread comes
out the same day as the oled model
maybe that's the time that those players
buy into it
but i am just one person who plays video
games with this viewpoint who also
is privileged enough to own two switches
so
take from that what you will anyways
thank you so much for watching let me
know if you agree with this or if you
adamantly disagree with this or if
you're just really upset that you didn't
get what you want or maybe
you're coming here to figure out whether
or not this is the one you want to get
okay i'm current davina thanks for
watching
like what you like play what you play do
what you do and just
enjoy for what it's worth cool see ya
[Music]
you